au sud-est de l'Ukraine c'est la ville
où les combats ont été les plus féroces
des dizaines de milliers de morts Mario
Paul ville martyrs dans les Russes ont
fini par s'emparer en mai aujourd'hui
ils organisent un référendum de
rattachement à la Russie même si la
moitié des habitants a fui
toute la ville et sillonnée de bureau de
vote mobile
bonjour monsieur vous voulez voter ça
vous dit
un scrutin en temps de guerre un soldat
accompagne en permanence les membres du
bureau de vote deux assesseurs nous
demandent de masquer leur visage par
peur des représailles le vote lui n'a
rien de secret
illégal pourquoi parce que tout le monde
ne doit pas voir ce que l'on fait
on vote sur la carcasse d'une voiture ou
devant une maison en reconstruction
ceux qui sont restés et qui participent
le font presque toujours pour la Russie
mais muni de leur passeport
ukrainien
je suis bien du crâne mais je veux
qu'elle devienne une Ukraine russe
au bout de la rue eux aussi ont voté oui
il dénonce pêle-mêle le coût de la vie
et la corruption en Ukraine surtout il
croit dur comme faire que leur maison a
été détruite par un tir ukrainien et il
n'en veulent pas une seconde à Vladimir
Poutine d'avoir lancé son offensive
nous a laissé tomber aucune aide il n'y
avait rien
nous n'assistons qu'à un seul vote
contre le rattachement je ne suis pas
d'accord sans trop d'illusions
on ne décide pas ceux qui décident ce
sont ceux qui sont au-dessus de nous
quelques habitants nous ont confié ne
pas vouloir voter mais cet homme est
bien le seul à oser le dire devant notre
caméra que Marie-Paule reste en Ukraine
je suis pour ça historiquement c'est
comme ça
ce référendum il n'a pas de base légale
au regard du droit international mais ça
n'empêchera pas la Russie d'utiliser le
très large oui qui est attendu pour
justifier l'annexion de ces territoires
tout est prêt à Moscou c'est une
question de jours